[Music]  having watched you over the last week I  don't see you really taking part in the  romance here or getting involved I don't  know I just see this guy that's kind of  drowning here and this isn't you you  know last time I was in an environment  like this I did think I was walking out  this was somebody that it was gonna last  forever coming back to a place like this  brings up a lot of weird memories death  and then to try to engage in  relationships here and know that the  last time I did this I you know it was  one of the best moments my life right my  fear is not entering interrelation my  fear is not pursuing somebody my fear is  that if I was to be broken again I'm not  full enough friend to recover from that  and then you have all the comments not  even mean  not even intentional but nobody realizes  how real it was they say  but you really love her it's really  character I actually get emotional  [Music]  [Music]